here we are in mikolov in southern  moravia  looking to buy some wine this is the  wine producing region  of texas of the czech republic but what  i want to announce here is that i'm  going to start a diary my blog is going  to become a diary i'm going to talk  about  what i do on a daily basis language  learning my routine i'm going to call it  i think it's a year in the life of a  language learner so i invite you to  visit my blog  and to see what i'm up to and i'm also  going to have different comments on  things that i experienced during the day  it's going to be a diary so i welcome  you to come and visit it meanwhile i  very much recommend visiting southern  moravia as noymo is a beautiful town and  here we are in mikolov and we're on our  way to visit ledmitse which is a  wonderful apparently castle so i never  knew much about this area it's a bit  chilly today i hardly recommend it and  also please go and visit my blog  a year in the life of a language learner  bye for now